welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and the question of
Wilfred or one-foot has finally been
answered
the eighth entry in season one comes
with a number of big reveals that we
definitely need to talk about throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down everything you need to know about
the latest episode it's ending and where
things could be heading now there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet that I
highly recommend that you check out now
please drop a thumbs up if you've been
enjoying the breakdown so far and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day without the
way thank you for clicking this let's
get to our breakdown of snowpiercer
episode 8 ok so as always we get a cold
opening to kick start the show this time
it's through the eyes of one of our
favorite characters which is Ruth she
cleans up the first-class carriage and
sings wilford's praises whilst sparkling
the cutlery being born with a silver
spoon is often seen as a sign of wealth
and I think this has been purposely put
here to show that she pretty much cleans
up after the rich Ruth has clearly
always wanted power and in this episode
it actually seems attainable in some
ways as we know she boarded the train by
herself after being hired on the spot by
Wilfred and thus he saved her life even
if he forced her into a role of
servitude we know the person she
worships isn't really Wilfred but she
has an almost religious view of the
character and hopes that she gets to
meet him one day much like how people
hope they get to meet God she has of
course met him before but that's how
it's phrased in the entry and it really
shows her thinking towards Wilfred
there's some bitter irony here as
Melanie is actually the one that's
pretty much done everything Ruth is
praising Wilfred for and as we know from
last week she's staging an insurrection
we have said that Ruth likely suspects
Melanie is Wilfred but she can't bring
herself to accept it and thus lives with
an almost blind devotion that he's right
all-powerful and just speaking of
insurrection 'z we also watch his miles
sneaks through the car at the front
where the drivers and engineers are
based this episode is very much about
revolutions and he signals LJ to go to
the front
last time Leighton gave her a job
and we start to see what this is first
hand now I love that the password is
either rich as this is a catch phrase
that's been laced throughout the show it
adds to the subtext of the revolution
and basically means that once the poor
starvin of they will turn on the rich
and eat them
the phrase originates from jean-jacques
Rousseau and has been adapted for
several revolutions and uprisings
lending itself well here algea of course
has complete disregard for life on the
train as she's pretty much lived above
it and never struggled because of this
she's wanted to bring things crashing
down as she cannot see the value in life
and to her everything is a game she
doesn't even realize the phrase either
riches referring to her and it's just
happy with the chaos we also see a
picture of Melanie's daughter and we
learned that Melanie's daughter and
parents were supposed to get on board
the train but they didn't make it
and this died miles recounts how his
parents didn't either and that Josie is
his train mum
yikes we also hear Ruth utter the words
these are his revolutions and though she
means it in the sense of the Train
revolving around the earth we know that
it also refers to the tale and third
planning to overthrow the first class
and crew we see this first hand as all
of the group including best ride the
troops together I was actually surprised
at how quickly the revolution came about
but it needed to happen fast because the
walls were closing in on Layton best
goes to see jin-joo and she seems
angered that Bess has been helping
Layton however best flips things round
and gets jin-joo to pretty much confess
that she knew about Melanie Jinju
chooses the Train aka the society that
exists on board it because she's had a
very good life it's difficult to want a
fairer society when you benefited from
it not being and as we've said
throughout our breakdowns Bess very much
represents someone coming from the
bottom who's seen firsthand how bad
things could be initially prejudice and
her position of power and authority
corrupted her but through first-hand
experience with Layton she's realized
that the Talese were people too even
though the front demonized them speaking
of the front Ruth is called into the
Folgers cabin where they inform her that
melanie is actually Wilfred and that he
isn't even on the train we slowly learn
in the episode that it could be dead but
there is an alternate
that is making the rounds now shouts to
superhero Nexus who have been speaking
to back and forth over the last couple
of weeks about the show he's recently
done a video discussing the best
theories on it and in snowpiercer law is
actually another trend called ice
breaker which is a wilford vessel that
he could be aboard the show actually
takes place between the graphic novel
and movie and in the source material
it's revealed as another train so it is
possible that he's still alive on that
or they could have just curled the
middleman and killed Sean Bean before he
even got a chance to be in the show
however as this is part of the
continuity of the film we do know that
he will eventually be around so there
has to be some way that he comes back
anyway that's just a theory it might
turn out to be untrue but let me know
your thoughts below Melanie is called to
the front for a hearing where they say
that they've heard Wilfred is not with
them and this comes as a huge gut punch
as Melanie doesn't get him out the draw
we know that he's likely not riding on
board the train and this the the theory
that I've just mentioned does gain a lot
more weight initially Melanie denies the
accusations of her taking over from him
the LJ shows a photograph of her
daughter and this she's reprimanded this
sends her train into uproar and third
and tail make their move and I have to
say that this is one of the most
engaging snowpiercer episodes so far and
the pacing is absolutely perfect you
really get a sense of there being a war
on board and the showrunners have done
an excellent job of conveying this
Melanie is locked up and she does the
old I have something in a drawer that I
just just need to get now turn you back
now through this she alerts the drivers
in the front and Bennett orders happy to
share everything down before commander
gray can get to them how he doesn't as
he doesn't want to get killed when the
doors eventually open and there's a
Bennett has to lock himself in the
driver cabin with just miles now how
he's saying that Wilford is dead
might signify that he indeed is however
as we know the show is in the overall
continuity so he's likely somewhere else
Ruth goes into the quote-unquote engine
room and has a complete breakdown
realizing that she's been made to look
like a right bloody mug
Ruth is pretty harsh on herself but to
be fair Melanie did fool everyone
instead of letting everything come
crashing down gray and Ruth decided they
should be the ones to lead the Train and
this sort of ties into the Adam and Eve
aesthetic that was laced throughout the
ending of the movie that featured a male
and female character going on to create
humanity once more outside the train and
the religious motif is present
throughout the work learning itself once
more here we also see the tale and third
signaled their revolution with the use
of a red flag according to chambers
cyclopædia a red flag is the opposite to
a white one which means surrender and
since the 17th century red has been used
as a sign of defiance and a signal bow I
really appreciate it CCA and it's nice
to see a pop up asbestos courts latent
to the tale they also beat up the guard
that be a blatant earlier in the season
and even heads up the Train later little
little seven Easter Egg there I think
now Lane gives a speech that would make
Bill Pullman and Independence Day proud
and they head out however the brakeman
catch the paper maker it looks like
things are gonna come crashing down
until best manages to convince them
otherwise they realize they've been sold
a lion Melanie and that first know the
truth too and have a chance to really
upset the order now in the door room
order he goes to Henry and they bring
this sleeping soldiers out of suspension
these were put into the drawers all the
way back in episode one and I don't see
I'm sorry guys but I'd completely
forgotten about you they were placed up
top for a reason and it's good to see
them being brought out this and finally
used Ruth goes to see Melanie and she's
completely devastated as with all
catfish reveals she realizes her life
has been a lie this entire time but
Melanie comes out with some pretty big
news namely that she was the one behind
the great arc now we did know that
Melanie designed it but it also seems
that she's being pretty much running the
entire thing anyway whilst Wilfred just
kind of viewed it as something to throw
money at whilst he never really believed
in it
Melanie reveals that she dumped Wilfred
years ago in order to save everyone and
though she does say she left him to die
the fact that this wasn't confirmed does
leave a lot of things open as we know
there are sooo
that allow you to survive in the
wilderness and there is potentially
another train out there a still really
can't see Sean Bean being cast in the
role just for that 3 second voice cameo
so I really do think that he'll either
be bunker down somewhere or abort
icebreaker and currently traveling the
world snow PSA is really snot what you
think and gross Jennifer what wait be a
nose man what's wrong with you now in
the draw room they wake up strong boy
who was initially a mute before he went
into it but he's now able to speak
Mandarin underneath the carriages the
army charges the tale and they get
impaled with this spear shooter great
rise a PSA movement but he stopped by
artist from the tale that used the
balcony in the night car to kill them
it's an excellent action scene that has
latent darling predator brights as he
fights through the carriage absolutely
loved one-shot action scenes and here
it's used to great effect to make for a
brilliant battle now you might remember
at the start of the season that Layton
was actually the one that gave command a
great score so seeing the two go
head-to-head is a really really good
moment gray kills someone in front of
Layton and I really can't wait to see
where their rivalry goes they managed to
take the night car but just as it seems
they're making some headway they're
forced to fall back we also get a big
twist when we learned that Trevor from
GTA has been taken out of a draw by the
first and they pile him with luxuries
before asking him to sell out Layton
he clearly bears a grudge after being
forced into the draws and it's an
awesome way to close things out he kind
of feel like Layton even if he manages
to get control of the Train won't know
what to do with it and yeah there's
already a lot of people against him it
might even get to a point where they
have to free Melanie and get her on
their side as she knows the inner
workings of it and as we've seen she's
one of the only people that can fix it I
love how there's now sort of three sides
with there being the tail first and
Melanie actually thinks she will come
out of things looking good and who knows
the new first class who might be
destroyed leaving room for her to come
in and seize power once more anyway this
was the best episode of my opinion and
it completely flew by but obviously
loved hear your thoughts on the show and
what you want to see in the last two
episodes
come on below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of the series so far just
in case you've missed anything you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate you and it's a
thank you you get access to content
early we want to come chat you so after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the disk or link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep it a date with the channel
so hopefully we see over there very soon
you